[Music]
Another Tik Tok video *claps* YES
'I was hoping you would make another Tik Tok video'
I know you are welcome
This is why I'm (realizes truth) losing against T-Series
Listen up kids T-Series is spending ads on television
Ok I'm getting that bread papa needs that bread
Don't discriminate watch the videate
Let's just jump into it
*I'm Already Tracer song plays*
What is he holding? Is that a oh it's a microphone. *Laughs*
You know when is this meme going to die? Never!
This girl will just be bullied into infinity
[Music]
You gotta appreciate it
It's like everyone wanted Vine to come back.
Here it is *pause* this is it
I'm starting to you know what im okay with it
You know what I'm okay with it
You know what I like Tik Tok. Screw you haters
Why do I have the green screen if I can't even key out my sweater
[The gosh darn Tracer song again]
[Laughs]
This is how real gamers play, just massage your friends scalp
That's how you unlock a tactical nuke
[The Office theme that then continues to sans the mans]
That's pretty
[Screams]
That's a forbidden song
[Music]
[Laughs] So good
It's like Vine *pause* with bullying
*struggles to find how to express his love for Tik Tok* It can't get better than this I don't think so
[Tracer song] Ok this meme can just stop ok just stop the winston meme
We done it now
We done the tracer. We done the winston and we nerf the bastion.
Now stop it
You're pretty
Pretty gay!! ;D
You know you think Tik Tok memes are gonna peak
but they just keep going stronger
[Music]
*yells*
daaaaaamn
how did he do that can we get a replay on that one, Brad
[weird Music]
he's the Chosen One
Love the dead face as well *chuckle*
You know something is wrong when
people stacking cups
are bullying you *weird chuckle*
welcome to twenty-eighteen
where the bullied bullies
you, *wheeze* I love it
It's fantastic
[Music]
No nut November!
No Nut
Life
*snort*
*wheeze* ooOOAAO
Think about that for all of you
that failed No Nut November
[Sad Music]
Think about the people with no arms
How do you think they feel?
*video: ok Bull's eye*
right here, watch this
*clunk*
gawd dammit
it's not a ylyl look I'm still in the
game *chuckle* they're so dumb
kinda like it tho
you know cause youtube has always been overflown with these
stupid, uhh, 'Vines that make me
want to die' or 'Vines that makes me
want to go to the dentist' or
'Vines that makes me want to finger my -' *censor sound*
just to see if it smells bad down there'
but now we finally just have Tik Tok
videos again and all that you have to do is
replace the music and you got yourself a
CPM (Cost per mille is a commonly used measurement in advertising.) like the adpocalypse
never happened baby because
i guess I don't care *in video: Take two steps forward if you've ever gotten
a Victory Royale
Take two steps forward if your
Dad loves you
Take two steps forward
if your Minecraft girlfriend
broke up with you
*sad bgm* I don't know why Minecraft girlfriends out of all
breeds, have to be the th*ttiest
of them all. You think you meet someone that truly
matters, You think you meet someone
that you can finally settle down with
never fall for a Minecraft girlfriend
they'll break your goddamn heart
after they break your house like a Creeper
in the dark
*uplifting music* (That's a neck)
Alright, I- I take back pretty much everything positive
I've said, about Tik Tok *chuckle*
Jesus Christ
This is what kids are doing these days. 'You know what I
I- I- I got an idea
Gonna stick a phone in my mouth
print a dozen papers of hand emojis
And that'll get me the clout on the internet that I deserve
*chuckle*
*music*
I don't know, I don't know what I was expecting
Is this a - that's the footage of me uploading a video to Youtube
Hahahahahaha
Let's get this bread Hahahahahahaha
I don't why I have the greenscreen, like
what is this? why is it reflecting on me?
what is happening?
I'm disappearing, guys.
Oh wait. No.
You know what - Brad is just gonna complain, so..
It's too late,
I might as well commit.
*dramatic musique*
God they're so dumb. That it's just
the perfect humour. it's just.. (I can't..)
It's the perfect humour for you
for you dumb balls ok I only laugh
at smart stuff
*dramatic music*
What is this.
Oh my god
*fantasizes about the dad he wish he had* I wish
I wish that was my dad.
*active music*
Oh my god, these -
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Aa-hooh!
Oo-ao-huh my
Ey Ey oh is it Roblox
*snort*
Okay that one's good, well played. *cute clap*
I almost got angry there for a second,  how could I be so
easily swayed
Grand Theft Auto Roblox
is one of my favourite games
*In video: If the furries ever have you down, just remember
good girls wanna be tracer, boys go to college
to hit the dab like whiz kalifa,
and weebs go to pluto
to get killed by naruto
jesus christ.
weebs to go pluto (hits chest)
to get killed by naruto
that is deep
like this video, this left a
profound impact on your life
*annoying music* Oh my gaawd! staap
I'm actually terrified what in the world
*dramatic music*
Is this google maps? Oh my god jesus
I wanna know where that is. Is that real?
This is what I'm talking about.
A Tik Tok bread
Everyone gets it.
Come on. Alright. It's not that
great but it's kind of
laugh-worthy at least. It's chuckle-worthy at least. It's kinda like my videos
You know there's no redeeming quality,
they're really not that funny
but, uhh, people seem to watch it anyway.
That's it!
We found it! it's a perfect match.
Outdated memes -  hnnm?
need I say more? I don't think so.
Why am Iaughing at this?
Come on. It kin- I don't know why I have to keep
make a case for every single one of them
like ok yeah that was
jesus stop
it's officially gone too far.
It's offic- a - eeh- yeh- You know what I keep saying
I say that every episode and then it goes further.
jesus chri-hahaha-ist.
uh my god
I'm scared. I'm beginning to get
scared. This is only the beginning
of Tik Tok. It's only been relevant
for like, what,  a month?!
I don't wanna know how this looks like the next year, ok.
mn-kay (replying to video)
euhahahaha
It's SANS! IT'S FREAKING SANS!
Okay, I get it.
One Tik Tok too many.
I definitely won't make any more.
You have my full honest word on that one.
You can trust- you can rely on me.
No more Tik Tok videos I swear.
Thank you so much for watching this video
If you enjoyed, SMASH like, subscribe,
I don't see why you wouldn't, honestly.
Has T-Series beat me yet?
I don't see how that's possible.
I uploaded a Tik Tok video. That's..
OKAYBYE